no Stargate
announcement until next
spring bucker welcome to S trck your
Sci-Fi TV and Movie
[Music]
Channel right okay so I finished filming
for the day tired filmed like four
videos
today but I just got an email from one
of my more trusted sources that says um
they have actually had a meeting um that
involved some Amazon reps talking about
delayed other projects and the subject
of um MGM projects was brought up not
specifically Stargate even though that
was mentioned a little bit later but
basically the announcement and what the
Amazon rep was saying is that um there
will be no Stargate announcement anytime
soon or RoboCop or a couple of other
things and it's because of the studio
space issue that I discussed with you
last week now I'm going going to be very
clear now and say that this is we have
to put this in the rumor category it's
not been officially um announced that
this is a problem it's an internal
business matter it's something
apparently Amazon are quite embarrassed
about and and um so they should be and
um it's something they are trying to
resolve very
quickly if you didn't see that video
basically Amazon let go a lot of its
Studio space that it Rents It doesn't
own any well it owns a couple of Studio
spaces at cver city but it doesn't
actually own any others so it hasn't it
it generally rents Studio space and
sound stages for its Productions or does
Productions in Partnerships with other
people that own them for example the
boys um that is made in partnership with
Sony Pictures and it is filmed at Sony
Pictures so um that's how their business
model has been for the last few years
but they are looking um in partnership
with um a few other companies um
primarily the Hackman Group which is the
world's largest private owner of Studio
space in the world um I said the world
twice in there in the world and um they
are trying to get Studios ni don't
forget that if you're enjoying the video
and you want to help support the channel
we need you a thumbs up on the video and
we need you to throw a comment on it
really helps with those tricky little
YouTube
algorithms how this is relevant to
Stargate specifically according to my
source is that they have e marked some
studio space in near Vancouver for the
new Stargate project this will be two or
three sound stages it will be where a
movie TV Etc will be filmed but they're
not going to be ready until next year
now initially the plan was to rent a
studio space and produce the movie and
then move across to this new studio
space this though was when they were
planning to film summer just gone the
strikes delayed that um from what I'm
being told is
now this the idea will be to begin
filming potentially
late summer Early Autumn next year just
because the studiio space becomes
available doesn't mean they'll be able
to start filming straight away
unfortunately there is a lot of early
development work being done at other
locations we believe there's some early
work been done in Eastern Europe but
again we can't confirm it um and that
early development work could be like
looking at things like um building
certain sets and building props but like
um not permanent ones so it'll be sets
just to sort of like Get visuals and
things and see how it looks and then
they will build um a more expensive
proper set once they work out the Kinks
building something like the new gate
they have to figure out how mechanically
it would work as well as aesthetically
how it works how it looks so we've got
that issue as well so potentially that's
happened but again as I said we can't
confirm so just to to recap there
because Amazon let go a lot of its
Studio space Jun strikes it was then
unable to get a lot of that studio space
back and there's a massive shortage of
Studio space right now because a lot of
Studio space is being
refurbished um the Hackman group again
is spending billions refurbish in a lot
of Studio spaces um we actually think
that the studio space that has been eem
marked for Stargate is possibly one of
the Vancouver Studios either the one
Stargate was originally filmed or
actually it's called Vancouver Studios
the Hackman group are redeveloping both
sites right now so it could be either of
those but that would be amazing if star
did get to go home um but yeah but a lot
of because a lot of that Redevelopment
work is going on and because just other
companies were just quicker to get into
rented Studio space that was available
Amazon have been left a bit flat footed
so they've already pausing a lot
of stuff that was already in
pre-production so stuff that was
actually already either in very very
early production or about to go into
production before the strikes happened
that's a lot of that's been delayed um
that's actually what this meeting that
my source was involved in was about was
about delaying these projects until the
new year um when space is going to
become available
um the reason why they're having that
meeting is because they're having to
delay contracts and things and they're
having to make sure that people and
stuff still going to be AA available and
it's know doing all that boring
practical stuff they're going to need to
do because of this delay so yeah we are
going to be waiting a bit
longer now I don't think this
necessarily means that Amazon won't
announce because they could announce any
point they could announce tomorrow and
say that we're developing and filming
will
start Autumn next year they could do
that but it would be saying that film is
going to happen in nearly a year's time
um talking to the source I'm say the
chances are they're probably not going
to do that they will only announce when
there's something exciting to
announce so um they will be they will
basically put Stargate RoboCop things
like this on pause right now while they
get all of these other projects up and
running they put all the effort into
that um and then they will come back to
these these projects when they're
ready there's no way this means starget
isn't going to happen it is is going to
happen it's just been delayed because of
the strikes and then terrible business
decisions on Amazon's part to save a few
million quid
um I just I still can't quite get my
head around that they've done this to be
honest but they could announce tomorrow
that they're in that it's in development
we could get an official announcement
really at any point I just don't think
we will because by the time they're then
actually go into film and people are
forgotten about it and then by the time
it's released it's going to be nearly 3
years down the line
um because that's what we're looking at
now we're looking at like 2027 or 2026
at the earliest for a
movie I'm just hoping that they change
their minds and they go for a series
first because that could be that could
be on our
screens end of next year or early the
year after early 2025 that could be on
our screens let's hope they change their
mind but anyway um so I don't think
they'll announce yet simply because they
want to buzz they want to build
excitement and if there's too big a gap
the excitement goes doesn't it it fades
and people are aren't bothered so
yeah so yeah that's where we're at right
now I'm going to do a live probably in a
couple of days and we'll talk about this
a bit more and hopefully I'll get a bit
more information I have already emailed
a other source to try and get a little
bit more info um but right now it's not
great news not just for Stargate but for
any of the big MGM projects that we were
looking forward to including RoboCop Etc
and Legally Blonde three that might get
delayed
too and as I said for the stupidest
reason but guys get into the comments
tell me what you think is this sort of
expected I think a lot of you guys did
expect that we wouldn't get an
announcement till the new year I'm
wondering now if they'll announce at San
Diego ComicCon 2024 like they were going
to announce San Diego ComiCon
2023 um I do wonder if they might wait
for that get actors on stage you know
and do a big splashy announcement
um but that's means they'll announce in
June and then start filming two or 3
months after that to be honest that
timeline probably makes sense but guys
what do you think to get in the comments
and tell me if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification it really helps us out
and you'll never miss any of our new
videos because we will go live as soon
as we get information or I will get
videos out the second I get information
if you don't want to miss them hit the
Bell notification also you go to c.co
which is our dedicated website where we
your articles based on most of our
stories we try to add a little bit more
info also you can go to patreon.com for/
sidre where most of our videos Premier
first as always please stay safe and
I'll see you next
[Music]
time